so i know that you're a fan of the
thomas soul quote where he says there's
no solutions only trade-offs
and this is something
in a roundabout way that same concept is
probably one of the most meaningful
things i've learned this year
what does that quote mean to you or how
have you how have you um
reflected on that
well especially from a leadership
perspective
that's kind of where i talked about it
for the first time how the heck did you
hear that quote from me that's i don't
know when i've said that i guess i could
do some podcasts about it but
yeah it's a it's it's very helpful to
people's mindsets i think and that's
when i when i talked about that it was
primarily to help people see
that you're looking for a full-on
solution to this problem and there's
probably not a full-on solution that's
going to satisfy every every aspect of
this scenario
so what you have to do instead is you
have to look for what what's the
trade-off going to be i'm going to win a
little bit here i'm going to lose a
little bit there but overall it's going
to move me in the right direction i
think it's a good thing to understand as
opposed to going through life thinking
that you're going to find a 100 solution
because it's not going to exist so
you're going to have to make trade-offs
in life
douglas murray came on the show and he
was talking about this
story from christopher hitchens where uh
hitch told him that in life we have to
choose our regrets
and what he meant by that was the fact
that opportunity cost demands
that you're going to have regrets and
i'd always thought that regrets were a
bug not a feature of life i didn't
realize that they were baked into the
literal fabric of how we exist
so you could make the perfect decision
yep
and still look back and have regrets
about not making the other ones simply
because of that open loop that we were
talking about before yeah you don't know
what the other thing could have been i
was like okay so well that's interesting
that
regrets are a feature not a bug what
does it mean that you need to choose
them
okay well
given the fact that regrets are baked
into the fabric of life
when you're making a decision one of the
things that you need to consider is
which of these regrets can i live with
and which of these regrets can i not
live with
and that there's no solutions only
trade-offs thing speaks to the same
energy
100 percent do you own a house yes so
when you're the a real estate agent told
me this years and years ago
when you're looking at a house there's
gonna be shortfalls
there's gonna be problems with the house
that you're looking at
and whether it's gonna be even if it's
the perfect house well that means it's
gonna cost a ton so that's the trade-off
that you're gonna make and so what you
have to do is you have to break down
like what you just said hey listen i
wanted a bigger yard but this one has a
huge garage
i'm gonna go with it you just gotta
figure out those trade-offs there's no
solutions you're not gonna get the
perfect house until you build one and
even when we build one guess what you're
gonna look at it when you're done and
you're gonna say i should have moved
this wall
24 inches to the west
right it's
it'll it'll each up what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace